C'est frisquet
Le froid, c'est quelque chose qu'on utilise pour soigner depuis déjà très longtemps
De la poche de glace pour arrêter les saignements et limiter les hématomes
au grand bain glacé pour favoriser la récupération des sportifs
en passant par la fameuse bombe magique
Mais depuis quelques années, une solution un peu plus perfectionnée s'est développée : la cryothérapie
Le terme "cryothérapie", ça vient de "cryo" qui signifie
"J'ai compris en fumant que fumer c'est de l'argent, que les gens donnent..." (extrait Tryo)
Non ça vient du grec "cryo" qui veut dire "froid" et de "thérapie" qui veut dire "thérapie" = soigner par le froid
C'est très utilisé par les sportifs, je suis à peu près sûr que vous en avez déjà vus
avec un swag et une badasserie assez aléatoires
Mais mieux qu'un long discours, je vous propose d'aller voir comment ça se passe, en vrai
Alors là, ce dont on parle c'est de "cryothérapie corps entier",
c'est-à-dire que c'est tout le corps qui est soumis à un froid très intense
Il en existe plusieurs formes comme la chambre cryogénique
qui est une pièce dans laquelle on fait baisser la température
mais là, en l'occurence, c'est un cryo-sauna
Avant de commencer, on a vérifié que mon état de santé était compatible avec l'exposition au froid
que j'allais bien au niveau cardio-vasculaire, que ma peau était saine
et que je n'avais pas d'allergies au froid
... ça existe
Ah d'ailleurs au sujet de la peau, vous avez été quelques-uns à attirer mon attention
sur la mésaventure d'Emma CakeCup, qui a été brûlée après une séance de cryothérapie
Ce genre de problème peut apparaître si une zone de la peau est humide
soit à cause de l'air ambiant, soit parce qu'on a mis une crème corporelle
Et oui, parce que ce qui est humide, ça gèle et ce qui gèle, ça brûle
... donc attention
Avant de rentrer dans la cabine de cryothérapie, évidemment on se change hein
enfin, on se met en chaussettes, gants et sous-vêtements
pour protéger les extrémités un peu sensibles
Oh, oh putain, la dégaine du mec
Pendant ce temps là, la cabine est préparée et la température à l'intérieur descend sous les 80 degrés
C'est le niveau 1
*toussements*
Ce qui crée le froid, c'est de l'azote liquide, vous savez comme pour les verrues
Attention, là, l'azote n'est pas en contact direct avec la peau
il est dans un circuit fermé qui refroidit l'air, qu'est ensuite injecté dans la cabine
Ensuite, bah, y'a plus qu'à y aller
Ah c'est frisquet, alors
Alors, je vous cache pas que c'est très vivifiant
... ouh
Un petit conseil, on évite de toucher les parties métalliques, pour pas rester collé
Une fois qu'on est dedans, la température continue à baisser
jusqu'à passer sous les - 150 degrés et la séance dure 3 minutes
On a pas idée à quel point ça peut être long 3 minutes
Les premières sensations, à part le froid bien sûr,
c'est des picotements sur la peau et puis assez rapidement
une sorte de douleur au niveau des articulations
notamment celles qu'ont souffert
Donc là, j'ai déjà les tétons qui pointent, là ça va être palpable
Là je sens qu'il se passe des choses au niveau de mes chevilles
qui sont mon point sensible
Evidemment, y'a la réaction à laquelle vous vous attendez toutes et tous
Donc là, mon pénis est une noix de cajou actuellement
j'ai perdu mon pénis
Bon bah finalement à quoi ça sert tout ça et surtout comment ça marche ?
La cryothérapie est essentiellement utilisée par les sportifs
parce que le choc thermique qu'elle créée favoriserait la récupération
en stimulant la circulation sanguine et la filtration des toxines par les reins
Elle déclencherait aussi une réaction anti-inflammatoire susceptible d'agir sur les petites lésions musculaires
La technique est d'ailleurs aussi utilisée par des patients qui veulent soulager certaines douleurs chroniques
comme la fibromyalgie par exemple
Par le même mécanisme hein mais aussi en ralentissant la transmission
des influx nerveux et la conduction de la douleur
Alors vous l'avez remarqué, j'utilise le conditionnel, la raison est très simple
il n'y a pas de réelles études scientifiques qui prouvent avec certitude tous ces phénomènes
Ça veut pas dire que ça marche pas, ça veut juste dire
que pour le moment, ça n'a pas été prouvé scientifiquement
Mais comme beaucoup de médecins du sport, d'athlètes et de malades
ont notés des résultats positifs, la cryothérapie est de plus en plus utilisée
Certains instituts de cryothérapie parlent aussi de vertus amincissantes
Ça ferait brûler des calories et fondre les bourrelets
... c'est tentant hein
Bizarrement, j'ai chaud aux fesses
Bon, sans surprise, évidemment, c'est pas la solution miracle hein ça se saurait
Là encore, il n'y a aucune preuve scientifique de l'efficacité de la méthode
Et là, pour le coup, je dis ça vraiment pour être poli
En tout cas moi, j'ai pas vu d'effets sur mes poignées
J'ai l'impression d'être un jarret de porc dans un bouillon
Dernier détail qui vous intéresse sans doute
ça coute 40 € la séance
et selon les cas, il faut en faire plusieurs
Bon, globalement pour résumer l'expérience
je dirais que ça ressemble assez fidèlement à l'idée que je me faisais
de me retrouver à poil par - 150 degrés
Mais bon, je me suis réchauffé très vite et j'ai même eu droit à un café
Une fois dehors, j'ai eu un bon petit coup de boost
avec une furieuse envie d'aller courir
Mais 4 heures plus tard, j'ai eu un bon coup de barre
C'est normal et c'est bien la raison pour laquelle
certains font des séances pour lutter contre les problèmes d'endormissement
... faut juste bien calculer l'heure de son rendez-vous
Alors, encore un peu plus tard
je veux pas mentir, j'ai eu des troubles d'ordre digestif
une bonne grosse chiasse comme on dit dans le jargon
Bon c'est aussi quelque chose qui peut arriver mais ça passe vite
Ah oui, un moment j'ai dit un truc, je suis presque sûr que ça vous a interpellé
"J'ai perdu mon pénis"
Et beh si ça vous intéresse de savoir pourquoi
le pénis devient tout petit quand il fait froid
je vous propose d'en reparler dans une prochaine vidéo
D'ici là, mettez-vous bien et dans le même temps, par pitié, portez-vous bien !